Elementary-aged astronauts,
fights with wild tigers,
and stop-motion horror decades in the making.
From slasher flicks to period piece thrillers,
these are the sleeper hit movies of 2022.
As the horrors of school shootings have become a
terrifying and tragic part of everyday reality for
American youths, it can be difficult to imagine
how to begin to tackle this topic in the context
of a movie. In contrast to the tone-deaf stab
at relevance showrunners made in the "Shooting
Star" episode of Glee, The Fallout tackles the
psychology of a teenager living in the wake of
a school shooting with depth and specificity.
That teenager in question, Vada Cavell,
experiences trauma extending far beyond just
the school shooting event itself. Just trying to
go back to high school becomes an enormous trial,
and her outlets for controlling her anxiety
aren't always as healthy as they could be.
The remarkable thing about writer-director
Megan Park's work on The Fallout is the
sheer variety she lends to each of the
high schoolers depicted in this story.
There's never one way to cope with trauma, and the
same can be said for surviving a school shooting.
Vada and her friends register as real human beings
thanks to The Fallout taking the time to outline
the specific and varied ways they're each moving
forward in their lives after unspeakable horrors.
"There isn't a f---ing reason.
None of us should have died."
Meanwhile, the lead performance
from Jenna Ortega is remarkable,
especially her subtle detailed depiction of Vada
shutting out those around her. The Fallout is far
from an easy watch, but it's an unflinching
and emotionally astute piece of filmmaking.
The people we lionize in society are just
people like everyone else. It can be easy
to forget that in everyday life, but Asghar
Farhadi's A Hero, which played at Cannes
in 2021 but hit Prime Video in 2022,
is a perfect reminder of this truth.
The film tells the story of Rahim, played by Amir
Jadidi, who was recently released from prison.
As he begins to rebuild his life, he returns
a bag of money to its rightful owner,
making him a hero in the eyes of his neighbors
and community. However, Rahim's past comes back
to haunt him as dissenting voices begin
to question the validity of his actions.
Not only does this place his new reputation
in danger, but it also begins to eat away at
Rahim's ability to secure new employment
and stake out a post-prison existence.
The same nuance and richly detailed
characterizations that Farhadi brought to his 2011
masterpiece A Separation are once again present in
A Hero. These intricacies make the ensuing tragedy
of the plotline all the more compelling to watch,
as does the delicately thoughtful camerawork from
Farhadi and cinematographer Ali Ghazi. The
cinematography is especially unforgettable
in the film's closing shot, which leaves
viewers with a sense of unshakeable despair.
Boasting a 96% score on Rotten Tomatoes, and
bizarrely overlooked for a Best International
Feature Oscar nomination, A Hero is another
Asghar Farhadi gem that is well worth watching.
From A.I. Artificial Intelligence to
Bicentennial Man, there have been plenty
of movies navigating the relationship between
human families and robotic companions. However,
none of them have been quite like After
Yang, the latest film from director Kogonada.
This film chronicles a family
led by their father, Jake,
played by Colin Farrell, figuring out
what to do once their longtime robot Yang
abruptly shuts down. While determining the
next steps for this mechanical being that
was so important to his family, Jake begins to
uncover extraordinary things in Yang's memories.
This discovery suggests he was even more
complex and human than they could've imagined.
The contemplative style of filmmaking
Kogonada applied to his 2017 film Columbus
is alive and well in its follow up, but After
Yang is far from a reprise of the director's
previous cinematic effort. The ingenious
use of shifting aspect ratios, paired
with Kogonada's striking editing techniques,
gives After Yang a distinct visual identity.
Meanwhile, the quiet pieces of unique technology
and architecture surrounding the characters
suggest a broader near-future world without
overwhelming the story. The filmmaking and
melancholy ambiance are so captivating that
they make this movie feel like the very first
film to ever tackle the idea of distinctly
human traits lurking inside a robotic being.
The tale of Cyrano de Bergerac
has been captivating audiences
in various mediums for well
over a century. However,
no one has told this adventurous story in
quite the way Joe Wright does in Cyrano.
"Pleasure to meet you. Cyrano de Bergerac."
This 2022 film brings the story
to life as a musical headlined
by Peter Dinklage in the titular role.
The story of an expert swordsman who believes
himself to be too hideous to be loved by the woman
of his dreams, it's a tragic romantic yarn that
bursts off the screen with palpable pathos. This
is a movie that wears its sentimental belief in
old-fashioned love on its sleeve, and it's all
the better for such a cynicism-free execution.
This straightforward approach to the romance is
mirrored by the confident execution of the music.
From random conversations punctuated by
melody, to letters read aloud through lead
actor Haley Bennett's sensual crooning,
the songs spring from the lips of cast
members at any given opportunity. Cyrano
has no qualms about beating its own drum,
which comes in especially handy during its
emotionally devastating musical sequences.
Some may find it more hokey than moving,
but if you like old-fashioned romantic
dramas that throw subtlety and caution to
the wind, then Cyrano will deeply move you.
In the grand tradition of Rope or Buried, The
Outfit largely takes place in one location.
In this case, that singular backdrop is the
clothing store of cutter Leonard Burling, played
by Mark Rylance. He prides himself on making the
finest clothes possible for his customers, as well
as how he stays out of the way of the mobsters
who use his place to hold money and letters.
One late night, this shop becomes a hotbed of
activity when gangster Richie Boyle is killed
by a fellow mobster. Thus begins a night
of increasingly dangerous activity that
sees this mild-mannered expert in fashion using
all his wits to stay alive. Writer and director
Graham Moore does fine work utilizing this
simple premise and minimalist environments to
create an engaging crime thriller.
Part of the film's charm comes from Moore's
willingness to have dark fun with his material.
The R-rating provided the filmmaker freedom to
include realistic bursts of bloody mayhem and
impactful dialogue laden with coarse language.
Mark Rylance's years of stage experience
serves him well within the confined set, and
he manages to keep viewers engaged with minimal
resources. Unsurprisingly, the Oscar winner proved
the perfect lead for the tense thriller.
Some movies only offer excess spectacle but
no heart, others merely schmaltz but no scope.
RRR [R-R-R], an epic blockbuster hailing from
director S. S. Rajamouli, wisely decides to
deliver both of these ingredients at once.
This story concerns two men, Komaram Bheem
and Alluri Sitarama Raju, in 1920s Delhi. The
duo sparks up a deeply passionate friendship
without realizing the other's true identity.
Bheem is on a mission to rescue a young girl
who was kidnapped from his village while Raju
is a cop who demonstrates deep loyalty to brutally
cruel colonial figures like Governor Scott Buxton.
RRR delivers one riotously over-the-top action
scene after another. Any pretense towards being
grounded has been tossed to the wind in
favor of delightfully maximalist chaos.
At the same time, there's a genuineness to
how Rajamouli depicts the friendship between
Bheem and Raju that makes it impossible
not to get wrapped up in their bond.
Depictions of this duo standing strong and
fighting back against cruel colonial forces
also stir the soul. There's a beating heart to
RRR that lends deep humanity to a movie that
also features exploding trains and flaming
carriages. Tossing in a bevy of remarkably
catchy tunes like "Naatu Naatu," and "RRR"
becomes a cinematic delight one can't miss.
Writer and director Richard Linklater returns to
the world of rotoscope filmmaking with Apollo 10
1/2: A Space Age Childhood. For this production,
Linklater splits the story between the real
and the fantastical. Part of the runtime is
concerned with chronicling the exploits of
young Stanley growing up in 1960s Houston,
Texas, when the Space Race was everywhere.
The film is somewhat autobiographical for
Linklater, and authenticity reverberates off
these recollections of the highs and lows of
such an important historical period. However,
Apollo 10 1/2 also ventures into a heightened
yarn about Stanley being called in by NASA for
a top-secret mission where he gets sent to the
moon before Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin.
The combination of the disparate narratives
in Apollo 10 1/2 is fairly seamless,
and it's greatly assisted by Jack
Black's wall-to-wall narration,
which bridges the gap between Stanley's home
life and his voyage to the stars.
"Okay pause. Let's forget about all this for
now. We'll come back to this part later."
Even better, Linklater injects amusingly specific
details into Stanley's reminiscing about
childhood elements like his uber-paranoid
grandmother or how his mom could make
one ham dinner last an entire week.
The entire story is told through nicely
realized hand-drawn animated rotoscoping,
a welcome return of an artform Linklater used so
well on earlier projects like A Scanner Darkly.
With these qualities, it becomes quite easy to
recommend Apollo 10 1/2 as a trip worth taking.
When director Panah Panahi's Hit
the Road begins, it appears that
the film will focus on a married couple and
their two sons on a road trip across Iran.
Slowly but surely, though, Panahi peels back
the layers on this family and their excursion to
reveal deeper, darker truths. This is anything
but a normal road trip, and it quickly becomes
apparent that we're watching an exercise in
quiet tragedy masquerading as familial normalcy.
The film's power is especially apparent
in how each of the lead characters gets
a unique and distinctive point of view.
The intentionally cramped confines of the
narrative allow us time to get to know everyone
in this family while the restrained camerawork
offers subtle glimpses into their interior worlds.
Panahi's strengths as a filmmaker are
further reinforced by how well he can
incorporate bursts of dark humor into Hit the
Road without undercutting its ominous tone.
Above all else, Pantea Panahiha's performance
as the unnamed mother of this family may be the
ultimate reason to see the film, especially her
work in the film's devastating final sequence.
Performances like that, just like movies as
good as Hit the Road, are far from commonplace.
A24's horror fare has often
gone in artsy directions,
with an emphasis on long stretches of silence,
meditative wide shots, and abstract imagery. X,
a title from the studio thrust into theaters
in March 2022, goes down a different lane,
with its horror influences being more in the vein
of The Texas Chainsaw Massacre. With a 1970s porno
shoot as the backdrop, X is a different beast
compared to Hereditary or The Witch, but no less
well crafted. Like many of its predecessors,
this A24 horror film is a compelling watch.
As for the plot, the film follows a group
of young filmmakers as they show up at a
Texas ranch to make an adult movie. Needless to
say, things do not go according to plan. Writer
and director Ti West isn't reinventing
the mold here, but he doesn't need to.
This is a film that conveys a giddy glee in
playing with the grisly storytelling hallmarks
of the slasher movie genre, and getting
audiences all riled up with anticipation
by overtly teeing up gruesome
ways for characters to perish.
In between all that fun, there's even an
occasionally poignant undercurrent to X
about mortality and who modern society deems
attractive. These themes add some heft to the
proceedings, but if you just want to
watch X for the gore and titillation,
there's plenty of that to satisfy. X is
a departure from the standards of many
other scary A24 titles, but following its
own creative path serves it mighty well.
Jerrod Carmichael not only stars in On
the Count of Three, he also makes his
directorial debut with this extremely heavy
film centered around suicide. Specifically,
the film is about lifelong best friends Val,
played by Carmichael, and Kevin, played by
Christopher Abbott, committing to a pact that
they'll kill themselves by the end of the day.
It's a brutal and heavy premise told
with deftly executed dark humor.
"I don't listen to Alanis Morisette
when I'm going through a breakup,
and I'm not listening to Papa Roach
on the day I'm gonna kill myself."
Much of this comes from how screenwriters
Ari Katcher and Ryan Welch pull no punches
in trying to make the audience understand
these characters and their complex motives.
We're always in tune with the deep
psychological trauma that's making
them believe that suicide is a reasonable
option to escape their tormented existences.
The empathetic nature of On the Count of Three is
especially apparent in the mesmerizing performance
by Christopher Abbott as Kevin. A man just barely
keeping his long-simmering pain under the surface,
Abbott can break your heart with a facial
expression, and both he and Carmichael have
authentic lived-in chemistry with one another.
On the Count of Three is not an easy watch,
far from it. But those who are able to take it
in will be gifted with an impressive first foray
into filmmaking from Carmichael, as well as one
of the year's best performances from Abbott.
In her second feature-length directorial effort,
director Audrey Diwan delivers an extraordinary
piece of cinema in the form of Happening.
This production tells the story of Anne,
played by Anamaria Vartolomei, a
young woman living in France in 1963.
Her hefty ambitions for the future get
upended when she learns she's pregnant.
All Anne wants to do is get an abortion and move
on with her future, but abortions are outlawed
in France in this era. Now Anne has to sneak
around, speaking in secrecy and using subtle
glances to reveal her true feelings while
keeping her crisis from everyone around her.
It's an intense storyline that Diwan brings
to life with subtle but impactful power.
Among the film's many strengths is Vartolomei's
performance in the lead role. Handed a part
largely eschewing overt dialogue, Vartolomei
works wonders in conveying Anne's thought
process via quieter means. Diwan's direction
is also remarkable, with visual details like
a constricted aspect ratio illustrating how
confined Anne feels in her day-to-day life.
All of these thoughtful touches add up to
a movie you can't shake off once it's over.
Happening isn't just a sign of
Diwan's powers as a director,
it's also an exceptional ode to what human
beings endure in the face of inhumane laws.
In production for decades, Mad God is a labor of
love from Phil Tippett, an icon of the stop-motion
animation industry. It's a miracle this film
ever managed to see the light of day considering
that it took crowdsourcing to get the funds
necessary to bring this warped vision to life.
All of that time, effort, and money were
spent on a feature that largely eschews plot
in favor of delivering increasingly disturbing
visions of a post-apocalyptic world where
suffering is omnipresent. Doctors
deprive people of their guts rather
than save anyone while husks of human beings
are created, often solely to die in the abyss.
Mad God isn't just dark, it's relentlessly bleak.
While such a tone won't be for everyone, those
that can get on Tippett's wavelength will be happy
with what Mad God delivers. Running just a hair
under 80 minutes before the credits begin, Mad
God manages to constantly deliver unpredictable
and unnerving imagery brimming with imagination.
The various textures provided by the
stop-motion medium make the film appear
more viscerally appalling and unique.
It's hard to comprehend an entirely
computer-generated nightmare world like
this one being nearly as impactful,
just as it's difficult to imagine many other 2022
titles being as lastingly chilling as Mad God.
If you're going to watch anyone talk in a hotel
room for 90 minutes, it might as well be an
instantly compelling performer like Emma Thompson.
She takes on the role of Nancy Stokes in Good
Luck to You, Leo Grande, while Daryl McCormack
plays the titular part of a male sex worker.
After her husband passes away, Nancy decides
to finally engage in the sexual exploits that
have been a mystery to her for decades,
hiring Leo for an hour or two of passion.
"Number 3: we do a 69, if that's what it's still
called? I don't know. Um 4:
Me on top. 5: doggy style."
What sounds like a simple arrangement becomes
anything but as Stokes begins to open up more
and more to Grande. Katy Brand's screenplay
ensures that the dialogue between these two
characters is as humorous as it is revealing.
The boldly intimate scope of the project, which
is largely confined to one hotel room, proves
to be a boon to Good Luck to You, Leo Grande,
offering viewers a chance to understand the finer
nuances of this duo without any distractions.
What's more, the film allows moviegoers the
opportunity to appreciate the exceptional
lead performances by Thompson and McCormack.
Good Luck to You, Leo Grande is the newest
reminder that you don't need an enormous
story to make an engrossing movie.
One of the first scenes in Neptune Frost
depicts people chanting and banging on drums
in the grim domain of a mine where a worker
has just perished. These performers are an
aberration in this environment, but
that's the point. Within this sequence,
Neptune Frost has established that music can
appear anywhere. The same is true for things
like the spirit of rebellion, empathy towards
other human beings, and one's true identity.
No matter how much oppressive
societies try to stifle,
or even wipe out, these forces, they
will endure. Hinging on this concept,
Neptune Frost reveals itself to be a
stirring battle cry in cinematic form.
Directors Saul Williams and Anisia Uzeyman tell
the tale of Neptune, played by both Elvis Ngabo
and Cheryl Isheja, who joins a hacking
initiative. There's a visual audacity,
particularly when it comes to costume and
production design. In fact, this might be
the only film to feature a major character in
an outfit made completely out of keyboard keys.
Such elements reflect how this film
focuses on a collection of human beings
who can finally be themselves away
from oppressive systemic forces.
Insightful dialogue by the film's protagonists
reinforces the movie's touching exploration of
individuals finally discovering the space to
embrace their own identity. There's a beating,
captivating heart to Neptune Frost, which informs
its ceaseless creativity and unwavering rebellion
against fascism. Even the most jaded viewers
won't be able to resist something this stirring.
The way racism is ingrained into the fabric
of America and its institutions is such an
overwhelming part of reality that even beginning
to approach it in film can intimidate filmmakers.
The documentary Who We Are: A Chronicle of Racism
in America, hailing from directors Emily and Sarah
Kunstler, provides an expansive look at the
past and present of racism's impact on the U.S.
The story is told through the words of ACLU
deputy legal director Jeffery Robinson.
The film split between clips of him
giving a talk about the history of
America's racism to a packed crowd, and
segments depicting Robinson talking to
various American citizens about
this urgently relevant topic.
Who We Are is a heavy watch, as it should
be. The filmmakers and Robinson refuse to
distill the horrors of bigotry to
just flat readings of statistics.
There's a passionate fervor in
Robinson's public speaking skills
as he dives into the nuances of how racism has
informed key parts of America's foundation.
"Who controls the past controls
the future, and your children,
they are being taught that slavery
was a side issue in the Civil War."
Meanwhile, his interviews remind viewers
of the human costs of systemic racism
being normalized. The overwhelming
reality of intolerance in America
is superbly reflected within
the lens of Who We Are.